historically
what has been the dna or what a
synergist has looked like that have
brought us together
not the fear guy not the divide guy or
gal
from your and maybe you say i don't know
pat i i don't know if i can think of
anybody
but if there is a dna of somebody that
you've seen say the audience is
listening to this and we have a lot of
different types of audience that listen
to us entrepreneurs investors
political people athletes those who
watch our kind of content that we have
what has been the dna of somebody that's
brought america together
it's a really interesting question um
you know i think you can't understand
the united states as it exists today
unless you understand the american civil
war
you know i'm endlessly fascinated by the
american civil war
because it's such a it's such a point of
departure
from what the country was before to what
it kind of becomes after it
and i think that when you study and you
know as i've studied and like learned
about the civil war
um the thing that kind of strikes me
time and again
is you know lincoln's like vision of the
country is a really it's a radical
vision just in so much as
it's it's a departure in many many ways
of
what many people viewed the country as
pre-civil war
um you know if you look at the primary
historical test before the civil war
the united states uh are always referred
to as these united states
right like they're plural the united you
know these united states are these
united states
and then it becomes after civil war the
united states singular
uh and that is sort of a radically
different vision of what this country
was from its founding
so you know when he's sitting there in
like 1861 and 1862
and the r you know the the union army is
getting the snot beaten out of it by the
confederacy and things aren't looking
too great
you know the fact that he kind of holds
that course i think is you know it's
it's remarkable
and uh and there are many moments if you
want to play the alternate historian you
can go into the civil war and see how
you know maybe that one breaks
differently
and you know the south is able to secede
from the union and we have a totally
different country so
for someone who like brings that brings
the nation together in the way that he's
able to do it
there was there was no trend he was sort
of following i mean he
had the vision and you know against a
lot of very difficult odds
was kind of crap it was you know weaving
out of whole cloth
what this country was kind of kind of
wind up being in the 20th century so if
you like this sort of shortcut from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye